Lara starts us off this hour in
Washington hi Lara welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show oh hi Dave thank you so much
I can't believe I'm speaking to you this
is such an honor it was honor for me how
can I help
I'm just shaking Dave I'm just
completely overwhelmed my husband and I
both are we are we are former FPU
coordinators and we went backwards in a
big big way and we just want to make
sure we're doing the right things why
well I was finally diagnosed with
bipolar disorder type 1 and not able to
implement self-discipline a lot so it's
one of the symptoms to do a lot of
shopping and spending and I did a lot
until everything fell apart in early
January and I had a I had to go into
treatment and lost my work at the time
and all of a sudden that that really
hurt I'm sorry and it's one thing to we
made a lot of money and we just spent
all of it and now we have an eight
hundred and eighty-nine thousand dollar
hole how much of that's house so five
hundred and seventy thousand is on our
primary residence and ninety five
thousand is on our old residence that
we've been renting for a year we've been
spending the last two months
getting it ready to sell and it goes on
the market Monday and we're hoping it'll
bring 400 thousand which will cover the
consumer debt is two hundred and twenty
three thousand dollars that includes a
HELOC credit cards a 401k loan so the
same is how the investment property gets
you back to gesture
mortgage correct good and if we get a
good price it'll give us the emergency
fund so so we're we're thinking that
we've been talking for a couple months
like what would they say he would say
sell the house so the house sells a
house so you're selling the house good
I'm with you yeah okay then your
backdoor mortgage what your household
income this year it will be 180 because
I didn't work for the six months all the
way to 80 in the coming 12 most coming
year
Oh in the coming 12 months it should be
about 280 because I'm working again what
do you do I'm a consultant first
particular software good for you okay
well you guys obviously have the ability
to earn a lot of money and by selling
this everything's cleaned up except the
emotional damage that's the part I need
your help with if I hear you I heard one
of your calls this week I listen to the
podcasts all the time and I hear you say
don't look in the rearview mirror but
it's really hard especially when we knew
better
that's the the remorse is so bad because
it's not like we didn't know better
we've listened to you and studied you
for all these years well you're going
through your manic phase and manic
depressive and you go manic and you go
spending like a crazy person where was
your husband in that equation he was not
really paying attention the only thing I
want to look in the rearview ball the
only thing I ever want to look in the
rearview mirror for when Sharon and I
went through the bankruptcy the only
thing we sat down and say it is yeah we
need to forgive ourselves yes we did
some stupid but stuff yes we feel like
fools yes we feel condemned yes we feel
remorse yes we feel all of that but
that's only profitable to the extent we
learn something from our stupidity I'll
never do it again and that's what we
said to each other Sharon
and so that's when we quit borrowing
money and that's when we said we're
always going to be tithers that's when
we said we're always going to be on the
budget we don't make decisions without
each other and you know the pain of
going through that bankruptcy seared the
principles the positive principles into
place like burn them like tattoo them
you know on to us and so I I think you
have that opportunity here and you know
there's two sides to this equation as
we're listening to you I mean what keeps
this from repeating in my mind it's two
things one is you continue to do the
work on your emotions with your
counselor if there's medication involved
by god stay on it yeah okay
and with with a manic depressive it's
not unusual that's chemical in the mix
okay not everything out there is
chemical that everybody thinks is
chemical but that one is oftentimes and
so stay on your medication stay with
your therapist you don't let up on that
and your husband has to frickin stay
engaged he's gonna have to be hyper
proactive to make sure this that you
guys don't slip off into this because
he's walking with you're walking with a
limp and he's walking beside you holding
you up if he just walks away and goes
listen if you can do it this time and
you fall over I'm gonna smack him mm-hmm
you know because he wasn't paying
attention he could have stopped this
okay you were dealing with a mental
illness you were dealing with emotional
illness that you were fighting and
you've gotten the other side of it I can
tell by talking to you and you're not
completely healed I'm sure there's days
that all this but the idea that you put
some guardrails in place to keep from
running off the road again is what makes
the past okay to glance in the rearview
mirror and see but we don't want to live
back there and just beat ourselves up
either mmm I don't sit around and go
Dave you were an absolute fool you're a
dirtbag
you have no use on the planet
you're of no value you had a finance
degree you should have known better than
to go that far in debt and let some bank
take you down I don't talk about that
from when I was 28 years old I'm 59 I've
gone I've moved on but I haven't moved
on from the lessons that I learned
that's the difference and so you take
the lessons and you go okay I just paid
$400,000 worth of tuition after I
graduated from Financial Peace
University now I did graduate studies
right I mean that's what you did right
yes and the great news is you guys make
a lot of money the bad news is is that
means you can mess this up big again if
you don't stay working on your stuff and
your husband doesn't stay plugged in
walking with his wife and using a
backbone and being proactive you don't
have a choice you'll be right back in
the same soup again if you don't do
those two things but if you do them I
think you'll be okay